This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars, and I'm here with 99PI producer and reporter Christopher Johnson. Hey, Christopher. Hey, Roman. So I'm in New York City, as you know, and of course you are in California, and we're connected over Zoom. We are. It's good to see you. It's always good to see you.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯，和我在一起的是99PI的制作人兼记者克里斯托弗·约翰逊。嘿，克里斯托弗。嘿，罗曼。如你所知，我在纽约市，而你在加利福尼亚州，我们通过Zoom连线。没错。很高兴见到你。见到你总是很高兴。
And you're coming in crystal clear, which is great. And this is especially amazing, considering that my voice and my face are traveling all the way across the continent to you through wires, Roman. Infrastructure. Love it. And that infrastructure uses fiber optics. How familiar are you with fiber optics, Roman? Well, I think I know the basics.
你的声音非常清晰，这太棒了。考虑到我的声音和面孔是通过电线跨越整个大陆传到你那里的，这简直太神奇了，罗曼。基础设施。我喜欢这个。而这些基础设施使用的是光纤。罗曼，你对光纤有多了解？嗯，我想我了解一些基础知识。
It's light carrying information down glass fibers. I think I can, yeah, I can picture it. Excellent, excellent. That's exactly right. So at its simplest, fiber optics involves basically translating information like, our conversation right now, into pulses of light. And that light zips down those long glass fibers that are finer than strands of hair. And then that light is turned back into information on the other side. And this is what carries most of our internet. A lot of people might think
就是光在玻璃纤维中传输信息。我想我可以，是的，我可以想象出来。太棒了，太棒了。完全正确。简单来说，光纤基本上就是把信息，比如我们现在的对话，转换成光脉冲。然后这些光沿着比头发丝还细的长玻璃纤维飞速传播。接着，这些光在另一端被转换回信息。这就是承载我们大部分互联网流量的东西。很多人可能认为
that our information moves through the air, but it doesn't. That's interesting. Because I mean, it's easy to have this misconception because, you know, like even the way we talk about, The internet, we talk about the cloud and Wi-Fi. Like, it makes it feel like it's bouncing around in the sky. Totally. But in fact, the internet depends on a massive amount of physical fiber optics cables that are criss-crossing the globe. Some of those lines are on land, but there are also one and a half million kilometers, Roman Mars, of fiber-optics cables stretched across the bottom of entire.
我们的信息是通过空气传输的，但事实并非如此。这很有趣。因为，我的意思是，很容易产生这种误解，因为你知道，即使是我们谈论互联网的方式，我们谈论云端和Wi-Fi。这让人觉得它是在天空中跳跃。完全正确。但事实上，互联网依赖于大量纵横交错在全球各地的物理光纤电缆。其中一些线路在陆地上，但罗曼·马斯，还有一百五十万公里的光纤电缆铺设在整个
oceans, carrying our Zoom calls and our TikToks and our shitposts all over the world. About 95% or so of intercontinental traffic goes via submarine telecommunications cable. So our conversation is definitely going through cables. This is Jane Rafino. She's a researcher studying global subsea cables. No matter how wireless your devices, and no matter how wireless you think your connection is, there is always a wire somewhere.
海洋底部，将我们的Zoom通话、TikTok视频和各种垃圾信息传遍世界各地。大约95%的洲际流量是通过海底电信电缆传输的。所以我们的对话肯定是通过电缆传输的。这是简·拉菲诺。她是一位研究全球海底电缆的研究员。无论你的设备多么无线，无论你认为你的连接有多无线，总有一个地方是有线的。
Now, nearly all of the data moving around the planet, this second, Roman, is traveling across the bottom of an ocean somewhere. And the reason I'm telling you all of this is because there's about a million miles of these submarine fiber optic cables in use today, and they all owe their existence to the one. the one cable, the first, the original, the OG cable that started it all. Okay, tell me about the OG cable. It's known as the transatlantic telephone fiber optic submarine cable 8, or TAT 8.
现在，此时此刻，地球上移动的几乎所有数据，罗曼，都在某个海洋底部穿行。我告诉你这一切的原因是，今天有大约一百万英里的海底光纤电缆在使用中，它们的存在都要归功于那一条。那一条电缆，第一条，最初的，开启这一切的元老级电缆。好吧，跟我说说那条元老级电缆。它被称为跨大西洋电话光纤海底电缆8号，简称TAT-8。
It was the first ever fiber optic cable to cross an entire ocean, and it really proved what fiber was capable of. And TAT 8 has been on an adventure. So I want to tell you how Tat 8 came to be and how it was this huge part of a telecommunications revolution and how it paved the way for the Internet that we have today. Sounds great. Let's do it. Okay, so first, just a little bit of quick background. Fibreoptic technology did not start out as a way of communicating. Actually, at first, it was basically just this Victorian. era novelty.
它是第一条横跨整个大洋的光纤电缆，它真正证明了光纤的能力。TAT-8经历了一场冒险。所以我想告诉你TAT-8是如何诞生的，它是如何成为电信革命的重要组成部分，以及它是如何为我们今天拥有的互联网铺平道路的。听起来不错。我们开始吧。好的，首先，一点点背景知识。光纤技术最初并不是作为一种通信方式开始的。事实上，起初它基本上只是维多利亚时代的某种新奇玩意儿。
I mean, it was essentially like a Victorian party trick. They started to use fiber to transmit light, but it was more for like, you know, a decorative garden or a party trick. They sort of had this technology and they weren't quite sure what to do with it. And then into the late 19th century, you see fiber optics getting used in medicine, like doctors are using illuminated glass to light up bodies during surgery. But it really took until the second. in half of the 20th century for people to see the potential of fiber optics and telecommunications.
我的意思是，它本质上就像维多利亚时代的派对戏法。他们开始使用光纤来传输光，但更多是为了装饰花园或作为派对戏法。他们拥有这种技术，却不太确定该怎么用。到了19世纪末，你看到光纤被用于医学，医生们使用发光的玻璃在手术过程中照亮人体内部。但直到20世纪下半叶，人们才真正看到了光纤在电信领域的潜力。
And then in the mid to late 70s, you really start to see the first fiber optic telephone lines. And so what had they been using as telephone cables, like up to this point? Basically copper. So in the 1960s, phone cables were still copper-based. And that was a problem when it came to long-distance submarine cables that connected, say, like, the U.S. and Europe. Just because those cables couldn't carry a lot of calls before the line started to sound basically like shit, or it just became too busy for more phone traffic. Yeah, yeah. I mean, when I was very little, I do remember, especially long-distance calls.
然后在70年代中期到后期，你才真正开始看到第一批光纤电话线。那么在那之前，他们一直使用什么作为电话电缆呢？基本上是铜线。所以到了20世纪60年代，电话电缆仍然是基于铜线的。当涉及到连接美国和欧洲等地的长途海底电缆时，这就成了问题。因为在通话质量变差或电话流量过大之前，这些电缆无法承载太多的通话。是的，是的。我的意思是，当我还是个小孩子的时候，我确实记得，特别是长途电话。
They sounded long-distance. Like, you felt the physicality and the limits of the physicality of the wires. But we were just kind of used to it. Like, that was just our lives. Absolutely. And fiber optics offered an alternative to that. A fiber optic line could theoretically carry way more calls more quickly with way less static. Pretty good, right?
它们听起来就是“长途”的。就像你能感觉到电线的物理存在和局限性。但我们已经习惯了。就像，那就是我们的生活。绝对是。而光纤提供了一种替代方案。理论上，光纤线路可以更快地承载更多的通话，且干扰更少。很不错，对吧？
Yeah, big improvement, yeah. And so very gradually, these old copper cables were getting replaced with the new fiber optics technology. And not just phone lines. AT&T did the first. ever live fiber optics TV transmission when it broadcasts the Winter Olympics in 1980 from Lake Placid. And then they made this little promo film to brag about it.
是的，巨大的进步。所以，这些旧的铜缆逐渐被新的光纤技术所取代。不仅仅是电话线。AT&T在1980年转播普莱西德湖冬奥会时，进行了有史以来第一次现场光纤电视传输。然后他们制作了这个小宣传片来吹嘘它。
The latest communications technology was applied in transforming Lake Placid into a global communications control center. The potential of lightwave technology inspires predictions of space age, home information and entertainment centers in the near future. Clearly, when you have ads about your backbone technology
最新的通信技术被应用于将普莱西德湖转变为全球通信控制中心。光波技术的潜力激发了人们对太空时代家庭信息和娱乐中心的预测。显然，当你拥有关于你的骨干技术的广告时
that nobody can really experience. They're like putting all their chips in on fiber optics, right? This is the moment where the fiber optics revolution is about to happen. I mean, the new technology was impressive, but there were also big limitations. Fibro optic lines were still only available in a few places and for relatively short distances. And all of it is terrestrial. All these fiber optics lines are on land. So it's still pretty limited.
没人能真正体验到。他们就像把所有的筹码都押在光纤上，对吧？这是光纤革命即将发生的时刻。我的意思是，这项新技术令人印象深刻，但也有很大的局限性。光纤线路仍然只在少数地方可用，而且距离相对较短。而且所有这些都是陆地上的。所有这些光纤线路都在陆地上。所以它仍然相当有限。
There's also this other thing that had been lurking since even before fiber optics that's kind of threatening to squash the technology before it really even took off. Oh, no. Who's this villain? Satellites, Roman Mars. Satellites. So as soon as satellite technology developed, as soon as they started to put satellites for communication in space, a lot of these cable and telephone companies said, you know, well, we're, we're. cooked, everything's going to be satellites. These are the last cables. We're going to go straight
还有另一件事，甚至在光纤出现之前就一直潜伏着，它几乎要在技术真正起飞之前就将其扼杀。哦，不。这个反派是谁？卫星，罗曼·马斯。卫星。所以一旦卫星技术发展起来，一旦他们开始把通信卫星送入太空，许多电缆和电话公司就说，你知道，好吧，我们完了，一切都将变成卫星。这些是最后的电缆了。我们将直接
from telegraph cables to obsolescence. At the time, satellite technology was becoming more and more of a thing. There were already some communication satellites in use. And so, when it came to global telecommunications, the assumption was that satellites were the future and that they would be the thing
从电报电缆走向淘汰。当时，卫星技术正变得越来越重要。已经有一些通信卫星在使用中。因此，在谈到全球电信时，人们的假设是卫星是未来，它们将是
that fully replaced those old copper cables. And so why is that? Well, for one, satellite are in space. This was the tail end of the space race, and we were still pretty obsessed with the final frontier. And so beaming phone calls to and from a satellite hovering above the earth, how cool, man.
完全取代那些旧铜缆的东西。那么为什么会这样呢？嗯，首先，卫星在太空中。这是太空竞赛的末期，我们仍然对最后的边疆非常着迷。所以，向悬浮在地球上空的卫星发送和接收电话，多酷啊，伙计。
Like that was the future, not moving stuff through boring, dusty-ass copper cables. Yeah, yeah. Satellites were a genuine competitor because they could carry voice traffic a lot more cheaply because cables are incredibly expensive to build. And on top of all of that, satellite telecommunication was just simpler, at least on a diplomatic level. These cables that go between countries had to be built with consortia.
那才是未来，而不是通过无聊、尘土飞扬的铜缆传输东西。是的，是的。卫星是一个真正的竞争对手，因为它们可以更便宜地承载语音流量，因为铺设电缆的成本极其昂贵。最重要的是，卫星通信至少在外交层面上更简单。这些连接国家之间的电缆必须通过财团来建造。
So companies from different countries had to collaborate with each other. And with a satellite, an American company could just do it. With satellites, the U.S. could build and operate its operations. own equipment with pretty much complete autonomy, which the U.S. government preferred. Yeah. Well, I would prefer that too. Yeah. If you've ever been part of an HOA, you would prefer this too. Yeah, I get that. And so, despite all of its promise, it wasn't a given that fiber optics would be the future for big, long-distance telecommunications. But fiber did have one very big champion.
所以来自不同国家的公司必须相互合作。而有了卫星，一家美国公司就可以独立完成。有了卫星，美国可以几乎完全自主地建造和运营自己的设备，这是美国政府所偏好的。是的。嗯，我也会更喜欢那样。是的。如果你曾经加入过业主协会（HOA），你也会更喜欢这样。是的，我明白了。所以，尽管前景广阔，但光纤是否会成为大型长途电信的未来并不是板上钉钉的事。但光纤确实有一个非常大的支持者。
AT&T was at the front of the fiber optics evolution, mostly because they were the experts on long-distance telecom cables. They'd been laying subsea cables all over the planet for nearly like 100 years. They had all the know-how, they had all of the equipment, they were deep on cables. And so as satellites were kind of threatening cables, researchers at Bell Labs, which was a part of AT&T, they went hard on developing fiber optics. They teamed up with telecom companies in the UK and in France, and they formed this consortium.
AT&T处于光纤演进的最前沿，主要是因为他们是长途电信电缆方面的专家。他们已经在全球铺设海底电缆近100年了。他们拥有所有的技术诀窍，拥有所有的设备，他们对电缆非常精通。因此，当卫星威胁到电缆时，贝尔实验室（AT&T的一部分）的研究人员全力投入到光纤的开发中。他们与英国和法国的电信公司合作，组成了这个财团。
And then they came up with this plan. They said, hey, y'all, let's build a massive submarine fiber optic cable and run it from the east coast of the U.S. all the way over to Western Europe. This would be the first ever fiber cable to, across a whole ocean, super ambitious. There's a big difference between doing it on land and doing it at sea across almost 4,000 miles. And the idea that you would innovate with something that goes into the sea is not, was not
然后他们提出了这个计划。他们说，嘿，各位，让我们建造一条巨大的海底光纤电缆，从美国东海岸一直铺设到西欧。这将是第一条横跨整个大洋的光纤电缆，雄心勃勃。在陆地上做这件事和在海上跨越近4000英里做这件事有很大的区别。而且你会在进入海洋的东西上进行创新的想法，并不是
obvious. So this was really untested. Okay, so the researchers and scientists, they're going to make this leap that they want to prove, they need to prove that fiber optics cables are better than satellites. And so they start building this cable that's kind of never been done before, like an undersea fiber optic cables. They've done copper wires across the Atlantic, but never fiber optics. So how are they going to go about doing that? I mean, basically, they just pulled out all the stops. In the early 1980s, they started doing all of these stress tests around the world. They dropped some simulation cables into
显而易见的。所以这确实是未经测试的。好的，所以研究人员和科学家们要迈出这一步，他们想要证明，他们需要证明光纤电缆比卫星更好。于是他们开始建造这种以前从未做过的事情，比如海底光纤电缆。他们在大西洋铺设过铜线，但从未铺设过光纤。那么他们打算怎么做呢？我的意思是，基本上，他们竭尽全力。在20世纪80年代初，他们开始在世界各地进行所有这些压力测试。他们把一些模拟电缆扔进
the North Atlantic to see how things like temperature and pressure change affected signal transmission, to see if laying and recovering the cable caused any breaks in the fiber. Pretty fundamental stuff. Yeah. They also built a thing that's called the Ocean Simulation Facility to see if deep sea conditions mess with the cable's ability to transmit light across all that distance. And that was at the Bell Labs Homdel Complex, which by the way is where they now film Severance. Oh, cool. Yeah, and so things are going pretty well for Bell Labs until during one of their tests,
北大西洋，看看温度和压力变化等因素如何影响信号传输，看看铺设和回收电缆是否会导致光纤断裂。非常基础的东西。是的。他们还建造了一个名为“海洋模拟设施”的东西，看看深海条件是否会干扰电缆在如此长距离内传输光的能力。那是在贝尔实验室的霍姆德尔综合大楼，顺便说一下，那里现在是拍摄《人生切割术》（Severance）的地方。哦，酷。是的，所以贝尔实验室的情况进展得相当顺利，直到在他们的一次测试中，
they discovered breaks in the cable's electrical signal, and this was maybe something that could derail the entire project. And that is where we get to the famous story that the subsea cable industry gets very, they get very nervous when you mention the S word, and that is sharks. Oh, man. Yep. Sharks are coming. According to Jane, one of the lead researchers at Bell Labs had the shark teeth that had been pulled from the glitchy cable.
他们发现了电缆电信号中的断裂，这可能导致整个项目脱轨。这就是我们讲到海底电缆行业非常著名的故事的地方，当你提到S开头的词时，他们会非常紧张，那就是鲨鱼。哦，天哪。是的。鲨鱼来了。据简说，贝尔实验室的一位首席研究人员手里有从故障电缆中拔出来的鲨鱼牙齿。
Like literal shark teeth Roman Mars. That's amazing. I mean, can you imagine you've been running all these tests and hither and yawn over the planet to test this thing out? You got simulations going to make sure that this first ever subsie cable will be completely fullproof. and you've got to get it right. You test for temperature, pressure, tension, and here comes jaws. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
就像字面意义上的鲨鱼牙齿，罗曼·马斯。太神奇了。我的意思是，你能想象吗？你一直在全球各地进行所有这些测试来测试这个东西。你进行了模拟，以确保这条有史以来第一条海底电缆将完全万无一失。你必须把它做好。你测试了温度、压力、张力，然后大白鲨来了。登，登，登，登，登，登。
I mean, sharks were really the thing back then, if you remember. I could barely go into an actual pool in the backyard because of jaws. But were sharks like a real problem? That seems like even if, I don't know, an occasional shark bit an occasional cable, is this a real problem?
我的意思是，如果你还记得的话，那时候鲨鱼确实是个大问题。我几乎不敢去后院的游泳池，因为《大白鲨》。但鲨鱼真的是个大问题吗？这看起来即使，我不知道，偶尔有一条鲨鱼咬了一根偶尔的电缆，这是一个真正的问题吗？
I mean, in terms of finding actual teeth, in the cable. I shrug. There are competing stories, shall we say, around this. In terms of the faults in the cable, Jane says that those were probably abrasions from the seafloor. But with the stress and the high stakes
我的意思是，就找到真正的牙齿而言，在电缆里。我耸耸肩。关于这一点，我们只能说有相互矛盾的故事。就电缆中的故障而言，简说那些可能是海底的磨损。但由于压力和高风险，
and they don't want to take any chances with this thing, the engineers and researchers start doing all of these kind of hilariously thorough tests to figure out how to shark-proof. this cable. For example, they go to aquariums in Connecticut and in Florida and they
他们不想在这个问题上冒任何风险，工程师和研究人员开始进行所有这些滑稽的彻底测试，以找出如何对电缆进行防鲨处理。例如，他们去康涅狄格州和佛罗里达州的水族馆，他们
put these cables into the shark tanks and they dangle them like a toy right in the shark's faces. And really the only way that they could get the sharks to go anywhere near the cables is
把这些电缆放进鲨鱼池里，像玩具一样在鲨鱼面前晃来晃去。而他们能让鲨鱼靠近电缆的唯一方法是
they wrapped it in fish. So basically like, oh, my dog needs to take a pill and going to hide it in some cheese. And there was just like there was no correlation. There was no pattern, no evidence that sharks are particularly attracted to the cables. I mean, what I love about this is that this is a scientific test that a third grader would devise. It's so understandable. It's so great. I love it. And the good thing about all of these tests is that they made engineers add these extra layers of protection and insulation to the cable, which in 1986, they started to lay across the floor of
他们用鱼把电缆包起来。所以基本上就像，哦，我的狗需要吃药，我要把它藏在奶酪里。而且根本没有任何相关性。没有任何模式，没有证据表明鲨鱼特别被电缆吸引。我的意思是，我喜欢这一点的是，这是一个三年级学生会设计的科学测试。它太容易理解了。太棒了。我喜欢它。而所有这些测试的好处是，它们促使工程师在电缆上增加了这些额外的保护层和绝缘层，1986年，他们开始将其铺设在
the Atlantic. I mean, in some places, they're dropping the cable to more than 26,000 feet down. AT&T actually ran this pretty cool TV ad that showed their crews at sea unspooling the cable and dropping it off the ships. But today, we're no longer just a phone company or just a telephone network. And the whole time, the voiceover is just flexing about how this one new fiber optic cable was such an incredible leap in global communications. Supported by a worldwide intelligent network that will someday make it possible for people anywhere at any time
大西洋海底。我的意思是，在某些地方，他们把电缆降到超过26000英尺深的地方。AT&T实际上播放了一个非常酷的电视广告，展示了他们的船员在海上展开电缆并将其从船上放下。但今天，我们不再仅仅是一家电话公司或仅仅是一个电话网络。而在整个过程中，旁白一直在吹嘘这条新的光纤电缆在全球通信中是多么不可思议的飞跃。由一个全球智能网络支持，有一天将使世界各地的人们在任何时候
to be able to send or receive information. The cable ran from England and France across to a town called Tuckerton on the Jersey Shore, not too far from Atlantic City. By the way, there's even a plaque there now, and it marks the U.S. terminal for the transatlantic telephone fiber optics submarine cable 8, aka TAT 8. Wait, why eight? Well, because there were already seven transatlantic cables, but they were all copper-based. Okay, got it. So then in December 1988, they finally switched on this new, first-of-its-kind, state-of-the-art cable, and it worked.
都能发送或接收信息。这条电缆从英国和法国延伸到泽西海岸一个叫塔克顿的小镇，离大西洋城不远。顺便说一下，那里现在甚至有一块牌匾，它标志着跨大西洋电话光纤海底电缆8号（即TAT-8）的美国终端。等等，为什么是8号？嗯，因为已经有七条跨大西洋电缆了，但它们都是基于铜线的。好的，明白了。所以到了1988年12月，他们终于开启了这条新的、首创的、最先进的电缆，它成功了。
And AT&T decides to get Isaac Asimov to launch the cable to kind of make the first call. So they have a video call between Paris, London, and New York. And Isaac Asimov sends the first message and he talks about, you know, welcome everyone to this maiden voyage on a beam of light. I mean, it's really beautiful opening statement. I love it. I love that they always had this notion of the science fiction nature of their science. You know what you mean?
AT&T决定请艾萨克·阿西莫夫来启动这条电缆，算是进行第一次通话。所以他们在巴黎、伦敦和纽约之间进行了一次视频通话。艾萨克·阿西莫夫发送了第一条信息，他谈到了，你知道，欢迎大家来到这趟光束上的处女航。我的意思是，这真的是非常美丽的开场白。我喜欢它。我喜欢他们总是有一种关于科学的科幻本质的概念。你知道我的意思吗？
Like having someone like Isaac Asimov, like on the ready for these things. Just added some grandeur to all this stuff. Yeah. Okay. So they lay it down and they introduce it with all this pomp and circumstance. And you have Isaac Asimov there with his mutton chops and everything. I mean, you know, but then in the end, did Teday end up truly revolutionizing telecommunications? Oh, it absolutely did.
就像让像艾萨克·阿西莫夫这样的人随时准备好做这些事情。这给所有这些东西增加了一些宏伟感。是的。好的。所以他们把它铺设好，并以所有的排场和仪式介绍了它。你有艾萨克·阿西莫夫在那里留着他的羊排胡子等等。我的意思是，你知道，但最后，TAT-8最终真的彻底改变了电信吗？哦，它绝对做到了。
I mean, first of all, it was a quantum level. in capacity. TAT 8 could carry 40,000 phone calls at once. That's 10 times the capacity of its predecessor, which was a copper-based cable. And then there's the whole cable versus satellite debate. But when TAT 8 was switched on, the superiority of subsea fiber optics became very clear. How so? Well, satellites had this pernicious problem with latency, where the time it took for a signal to go up into space and come back down, it caused delays. Now, they were tiny, but they were enough to drive you absolutely nuts. And signal quality was only kind of so-so, but with TAT-8, things were immediately so much better.
我的意思是，首先，它是一个量子级的容量。TAT-8可以同时承载40000个电话。这是其前身（基于铜线的电缆）容量的10倍。然后是整个电缆与卫星的争论。但当TAT-8开启时，海底光纤的优越性变得非常明显。怎么说呢？嗯，卫星有一个有害的延迟问题，信号进入太空再返回所需的时间会导致延迟。现在，它们很小，但足以让你彻底发疯。而且信号质量也只是马马虎虎，但有了TAT-8，情况立刻好多了。
And TAT-8 proved that submarine fiber cables could actually be cheaper to make, to install, to fix, and data was way more secure, and fiber's bandwidth was way higher. And also, TAT-8 was coming into use just as the World Wide Web was taking off. So it was also perfectly positioned to fill the immediate demand for infrastructure that could move all this information all over the world quickly. So TAT-8 showed the world of international telecom that a long-distance sub-sea fiber optics cable could really basically crush it. In fact, it worked so well that engineers at the time,
而且TAT-8证明了海底光纤电缆实际上在制造、安装、维修方面更便宜，数据也更安全，光纤的带宽也更高。而且，TAT-8投入使用时，万维网正好开始兴起。所以它也处于完美的位置，可以满足对能够快速在全球范围内移动所有这些信息的各种基础设施的迫切需求。所以TAT-8向国际电信界展示了长途海底光纤电缆真的可以基本上大获成功。事实上，它工作得如此之好，以至于当时的工程师们，
were positive that this would be the first and the last cable like this that they would ever have to install. When it was launched, there was this belief that this is going to be so much capacity. We're not going to need anything else ever. I swear I'll never ask for any more capacity. And it was full within 18 months because, of course, you know, just like when you build a highway, it increases traffic. You build a cable and it increases traffic. So it's full to capacity within 18 months, which, you know, is not. a huge problem because more cables come after it.
确信这将是他们必须安装的第一条也是最后一条这样的电缆。当它推出时，人们相信这将有如此大的容量。我们永远不需要任何其他东西了。我发誓我永远不会再要求更多的容量了。结果18个月内就满了，因为，你知道，就像你修一条高速公路一样，它会增加交通流量。你铺设一条电缆，它就会增加流量。所以它在18个月内就达到了满负荷，这，你知道，并不是一个巨大的问题，因为后面还有更多的电缆。
So once Tat 8 proved the concept of international submarine lines, the FCC invested more and more in fiber optics cables. And so by the 1990s, the capacity of fiber optics overtook satellites and it just kept growing from there, to the point that today, we are completely reliant on this technology, with hundreds and hundreds of those sprawling subsea cables that are emmeshing the planet. it right now. I mean, it's really amazing to think about it and to picture it. But I do want to go back to the satellites for a second because they obviously didn't go away. So if most of the global internet's infrastructure is fiber optic cables, where do the satellites actually fit into that?
所以一旦TAT-8证明了国际海底线路的概念，FCC就在光纤电缆上投入了越来越多的资金。因此，到了20世纪90年代，光纤的容量超过了卫星，并从那里开始不断增长，以至于今天，我们完全依赖这项技术，数百条纵横交错的海底电缆正在缠绕着地球。现在。我的意思是，想到这一点并想象它真的很神奇。但我确实想回到卫星的问题上，因为它们显然没有消失。所以如果全球互联网的大部分基础设施是光纤电缆，那么卫星实际上在其中处于什么位置？
So today, satellites only carry a tainty amount of global internet traffic, but they are still a huge part of our internet ecosystem. And this is especially true for remote, low-connectivity places that don't have their own fiber optics lines yet. Or where maybe there's only one cable and it could be wiped out by a natural disaster, say, and in places like that, satellites are a lifeline for connection and for redundancy. But when it comes to total data capacity, it's not even close. Today, fiber optics are the way of the world. Well, this brings up another question for me, because, you know, who owns all all these subsea cables that were reliant on that crisscrossed the globe and circle it and send all the traffic around.
所以今天，卫星只承载了极少量的全球互联网流量，但它们仍然是我们互联网生态系统的重要组成部分。对于那些还没有自己光纤线路的偏远、低连接地区，情况尤其如此。或者在可能只有一条电缆且可能被自然灾害摧毁的地方，在这些地方，卫星是连接和冗余的生命线。但当谈到总数据容量时，它们根本无法相比。今天，光纤是世界的主流。好吧，这对我来说提出了另一个问题，因为，你知道，谁拥有所有这些我们依赖的、纵横交错全球并环绕它、发送所有流量的海底电缆。
I mean, you know, that one TAT 8 was a consortium of, you know, the U.S. and AT&D and France and stuff like this. Are there still like cooperative international consortia to make everything else happen? Mostly no. There are still some cables that are built or owned like that. But most submarine cables today, it won't surprise you, are in private. hands. For example, a small handful of companies install most of the world's subsea cables. And when it comes to ownership, the usual suspects. Google, Meta, Microsoft, and Amazon, together they either own or they lease half of all the bandwidth across the world's subsea cables.
我的意思是，你知道，那条TAT-8是一个由美国、AT&T、法国等组成的财团。现在还有像那样的合作国际财团来让其他一切发生吗？大部分没有。仍然有一些电缆是那样建造或拥有的。但今天大多数海底电缆，你不会感到惊讶，是在私人手中。例如，少数几家公司安装了世界上大部分的海底电缆。而说到所有权，通常的嫌疑人。谷歌、Meta、微软和亚马逊，它们共同拥有或租赁了全球海底电缆一半的带宽。
And now, thanks to AI, we are in the middle of a subsea cable boom. All of these tech giants need wires that connect all those data centers around the world. And so they're investing more and more in subsea cables. So, for example, there's a project underway right now to build what will be the world's single longest submarine cable connecting five continents. Now, as for TAT-8, even though it revolutionized global telecom and it played this huge role in the birth of the internet, TAT-8 won't be. part of this AI explosion.
现在，多亏了人工智能，我们正处于海底电缆繁荣的中间。所有这些科技巨头都需要连接世界各地所有数据中心的电线。因此，他们正在越来越多地投资于海底电缆。例如，目前有一个项目正在进行中，旨在建造将成为世界上单条最长的海底电缆，连接五大洲。现在，至于TAT-8，尽管它彻底改变了全球电信，并在互联网的诞生中发挥了巨大的作用，但TAT-8将不会成为这次人工智能爆炸的一部分。
What? Why? We'll talk about that after the break. Okay, Roman, we are back. We are back. And now I think it's time to have maybe a little retirement party for TAT 8. Retirement, okay. Because for as much as TAT 8 revolutionized telecommunication, the cable itself didn't actually work for all that long.
什么？为什么？休息后我们再谈。好的，罗曼，我们回来了。我们回来了。现在我认为是时候为TAT-8举办一个小小的退休派对了。退休，好的。因为尽管TAT-8彻底改变了电信，但这条电缆本身实际上并没有工作太久。
It was switched on in 1988, and it stopped working in 2002. What? Just 14 years later, I know. Wow. Okay, RIP, TAT 8. Yeah. And it was just sitting there. It's carcass.
它在1988年开启，在2002年停止工作。什么？仅仅14年后，我知道。哇。好的，安息吧，TAT-8。是的。它就一直坐在那里。它的残骸。
It's just been sitting there dead? Yeah, it's just been sitting there, chilling at the bottom of the Atlantic. And now, almost 40 years after it was installed, TAT 8 is finally being pulled out. So why are they bothering to pull it up now, like 40 years later? Like, it's been there so long. Why not just leave it? Well, ordinarily, that's exactly what they do. They would just leave the cables down there.
它就一直死在那里？是的，它就一直坐在那里，在大西洋底部休息。现在，在它安装近40年后，TAT-8终于被拉出来了。那么为什么他们现在要费心把它拉上来，40年后？就像，它在那里待了这么久。为什么不直接留着它？嗯，通常情况下，这正是他们会做的。他们会把电缆留在那里。
Yeah. They don't want to mess with the seabed and recovery can be expensive, and it's labor intensive. And there's sharks down there? There are sharks down there. But now, there are so many cables running along the bottom of our oceans and seas. And as vast as those oceans and seas are, there are actually limited ideal routes that we can run when you account for protected areas, military areas.
是的。他们不想干扰海床，回收可能很昂贵，而且是劳动密集型的。而且下面有鲨鱼？下面有鲨鱼。但现在，有太多的电缆沿着我们的海洋和海床运行。尽管这些海洋和海域非常广阔，但当你考虑到保护区、军事区域时，实际上有有限的理想路线可以运行。
So there's all this competition for seabed use, which means that now to make room, they've got to start pulling up some of those old lines like tat 8. Also, the tat 8 cable is made of all these pretty valuable components and those parts are getting stripped and recycled. That makes sense. That makes sense. So what does this process like? It sounds incredibly hard. I am so glad you asked because this is probably my favorite part of this story. I mean, I think it is just so, so cool how they do this, partly because even though our internet is based on this incredibly fast, efficient technology,
所以海床使用存在所有这些竞争，这意味着现在为了腾出空间，他们必须开始拉起一些像TAT-8这样的旧线路。此外，TAT-8电缆由所有这些相当有价值的组件制成，这些部件正在被拆解和回收。这说得通。这说得通。那么这个过程是什么样的？听起来极其困难。我很高兴你问了，因为这可能是我这个故事中最喜欢的部分。我的意思是，我认为他们这样做的方式非常非常酷，部分原因是尽管我们的互联网是基于这种极其快速、高效的技术，
it still takes so much labor and human hands to deal with this infrastructure, from installing it to maintaining it. and now recovering it. And I talked to Jane about this because she actually met some of the crew of a recovery ship. The ship itself can carry a crew of 14 people. There's a captain,
它仍然需要如此多的劳动力和人手来处理这种基础设施，从安装到维护，现在是回收。我和简谈过这件事，因为她实际上见过回收船的一些船员。这艘船本身可以搭载14名船员。有一名船长，
there are the coilers, there are a standard ships engineer, and they come from all around the world. And they go out to sea for two to two and a half months at a time. So they basically go out They collect a section of TAT-8 cable, and they bring it back. They offload it.
有卷绕工，有标准的船舶工程师，他们来自世界各地。他们一次出海两到两个半月。所以他们基本上出去，收集一段TAT-8电缆，然后带回来。他们卸下它。
They resupply the ship. They get more coffee and snacks. Maybe get some rest. And then they head back out to pick up where they left off. They use a set of coordinates to find and pick up the cable where they left off. They get out to where they generally think that the cable is based off this data. And then they take this flat grapinal hook. They call it a flatfish, which is attached to a long, long rope.
他们为船只补给。他们买更多的咖啡和零食。也许休息一下。然后他们又出发去从中断的地方继续。他们使用一组坐标来找到并拾起他们中断的地方的电缆。他们到达他们根据这些数据大致认为电缆所在的地方。然后他们拿着这个扁平的抓钩。他们称之为“比目鱼”，它连接在一根长长的绳子上。
And they throw it into the water to around where they think they can snag the cable. There are some sections that are really deep, so like three miles, three miles, even just like a three mile long rope is actually quite difficult to imagine because you can't see it all. And they're trying to catch a cable that is how big? The deep sea portion of tat eight, at least, is exactly the diameter of like a candle that you would stick in a candlestick on your table. And I know that because I keep my tat eight samples in an IKEA candlestick in my office. Oh, I was not picturing something the width of a candle. I was picturing like maybe like sort of a arm length diameter. Like if you put your arms in a circle.
他们把它扔进水里，扔到他们认为可以钩住电缆的地方。有些部分非常深，比如三英里，三英里，甚至仅仅是一根三英里长的绳子实际上也是相当难以想象的，因为你看不见它。而他们试图捕捉的电缆有多大？至少TAT-8的深海部分，直径正好和你放在桌子上的烛台里的蜡烛一样。我知道这一点是因为我把我的TAT-8样本放在办公室的一个宜家烛台里。哦，我没想象到有蜡烛那么宽。我想象的是像手臂长度的直径。就像如果你把手臂围成一个圆圈。
I thought that was the cable we're talking about. So how do they hook it? How do they get it on board? I don't even understand. So they throw the hook off the ship and then they slowly drag the hook across the bottom of the sea until like you're fishing. Yeah. They get a bite. They get a snag. And then they start winching the cable into one of the ship's cable tanks where there are these guys called coilers waiting to get to work. And at sea, it's part of their job to stand in the tank and grab the cable as it comes through the hatch. And they walk backwards in slow circles to coil the cable. And this is all just so fascinating to me because they have to walk backwards in these slow circles coiling the cable just right.
我以为那是我们谈论的电缆。那么他们怎么钩住它？他们怎么把它弄上船？我甚至不明白。所以他们把钩子从船上扔下去，然后他们慢慢地把钩子拖过海底，就像你在钓鱼一样。是的。他们咬钩了。他们钩住了。然后他们开始把电缆绞进船上的一个电缆舱，那里有这些被称为“卷绕工”的人等着开始工作。在海上，他们的工作的一部分是站在舱里，在电缆穿过舱口时抓住它。他们向后走着缓慢的圆圈来卷绕电缆。而这一切对我来说太迷人了，因为他们必须向后走着这些缓慢的圆圈，把电缆卷得恰到好处。
And they do this for eight whole hours. Oh, my Lord. Yeah, and because this can make you hell of dizzy, they have to take breaks. They have to break it up into half-hour shifts. One of the coilers describes the shifts as 14 cigarettes long. So you walk backwards for 30 minutes. You climb up the ladder, which is about 10 meters back to the deck. You have your two cigarettes and back down into the hold for another 30 minutes.
他们这样做整整八个小时。哦，我的天哪。是的，而且因为这会让你头晕目眩，他们必须休息。他们必须把它分成半小时的轮班。其中一名卷绕工将轮班描述为14支香烟那么长。所以你向后走30分钟。你爬上梯子，大约10米回到甲板。你抽两支烟，然后回到货舱再待30分钟。
That sounds grueling. Oh, it gets so much worse. They are out in the open ocean. three-meter swells. They're down in the hold of the ship, pulling in cable. It could be 30 degrees Celsius down there, and you're being tossed around.
听起来很折磨人。哦，情况变得更糟了。他们在公海上。三米的涌浪。他们在船的货舱里，拉进电缆。那里可能有30摄氏度，而且你被晃来晃去。
30 degrees Celsius, that's pushing 90 degrees Fahrenheit. And they still have to pull in the cable, stack it just so. And in the meantime, they're making sure that they're not sailing right into like a hurricane. Because that is the reality,
30摄氏度，那接近90华氏度。他们仍然必须拉进电缆，把它堆得整整齐齐。与此同时，他们要确保他们没有直接驶向飓风。因为这就是现实，
especially in the mid-term. to late summer in the Atlantic. And, of course, in the colder months, you're dealing with sea ice. I mean, the ocean is the ocean. True words are never spoken. The ocean is the ocean. Ocean gone ocean, really.
特别是在大西洋的夏中到夏末。当然，在寒冷的月份，你要处理海冰。我的意思是，海洋就是海洋。真理莫过于此。海洋就是海洋。海洋终究是海洋，真的。
Okay. So the parts they've recovered that they've pulled up from the ocean, what happens to it from there? Okay, so they can recover and bring back like a thousand kilometers of TAT-8 cable at a time, sometimes more. Oh, wow. And they take TAT-8 to a port where then it gets stripped apart and it gets recycled, basically. The only thing that they can't really reuse are those long glass fibers.
好的。所以他们回收的、从海洋中拉上来的部分，从那里会发生什么？好的，所以他们一次可以回收并带回大约一千公里的TAT-8电缆，有时更多。哦，哇。他们把TAT-8带到一个港口，在那里它被拆解并回收，基本上。他们唯一不能真正重复利用的是那些长玻璃纤维。
But there's also copper in the cables, and that's really valuable right now because there's a global copper shortage. There's also steel in TAT-8, and that gets pulled out and turned into fencing. And the plastic gets turned into consumer goods. So next time you're washing your hair, you can imagine that you could be squeezing your shampoo from part of what used to be the first fiber optic transatlantic cable. It's true downcycling right there. Like this thing that revolutionized communications is now, a shampoo bottle. That is hilarious. It's ironic to me that the thing that made it, this technological leap, the glass fibers are useless and all the stuff that's
但电缆里也有铜，这在现在非常值钱，因为全球铜短缺。TAT-8里也有钢，它被拉出来做成围栏。塑料被做成消费品。所以下次你洗头的时候，你可以想象你可能正在从曾经是第一条跨大西洋光纤电缆的一部分中挤出你的洗发水。这真的是真正的降级回收。就像这个彻底改变了通信的东西现在是一个洗发水瓶。这太搞笑了。对我来说讽刺的是，制造它的东西，这种技术飞跃，玻璃纤维是没用的，而所有那些
around it is what is harvested and turned into. All that shark proofing. Yeah, all that shark proofing is why it's valuable and why it can now hold your shampoo. I can think of no nobler of fate. Well, okay, so Tad 8, you had a good run. We stripped you for parts. You even got a plaque. We salute you, Tad 8.
周围的东西才是被收获并变成的东西。所有那些防鲨处理。是的，所有那些防鲨处理就是它为什么有价值，为什么它现在可以装你的洗发水。我想不出比这更高尚的命运了。好吧，好的，TAT-8，你度过了一段美好的时光。我们把你拆成了零件。你甚至得到了一块牌匾。我们向你致敬，TAT-8。
Thank you for your service, Tad 8. 99% Invisible was reported and produced this week by Christopher Johnson and edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Jane Rofino's story about Tad 8 appears in the May-June issue of Wired Magazine. It's got lots of cool pictures from the recovery ship. Go check it out. We'll have a link in the show notes.
谢谢你的服务，TAT-8。《99% Invisible》本周由克里斯托弗·约翰逊报道和制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德配乐。格雷厄姆·赫沙事实核查。简·罗菲诺关于TAT-8的故事出现在《连线》杂志5月-6月刊上。它有很多来自回收船的酷照片。去看看吧。我们会在节目说明中提供链接。
Special thanks this week to historian Bill, the cable guy Burns, and Jeff Hecht. Kathy Two is our executive producer. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Burubei, Jason Deli. Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lay, Lashemadonne, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talent and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building.
本周特别感谢历史学家比尔、“电缆人”伯恩斯和杰夫·赫克特。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·布鲁贝、杰森·德利、里昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·莱、拉什马多恩、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔伦和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99% Invisible》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Series XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。
In beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI. at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。